pour nous c'est très important que
l'Union Européen et les États membres
ont déployé des efforts extraordinaires
pour nous apporter de l'assistance dans
toute les domaines clés échanges
commerciaux économique énergie transport
soutien financière notre coopération
dans le domaine militaire et sécuritaire
s beaucoup renforcé l'Union européenne a
récemment ouvert une mission civile de
conseil en République de Moldavie pour
renforcer la résilience du secteur de la
sécurité par la mission de partenariat
de l'Union europé
de même
euh cette année le Pays-Bas et la
Belgique ont annoncé l'ouverture des
ambassades à kishenau le Luxembourg a
accrédité le premier ambassadeur non
résident pour la Moldavie la Grèce et
l'Espagne ont annoncé leur intention
d'ouvrir les ambassades à kishinao
jusqu'à la fin de l'année et encore une
fois c'est un preuve pour nous de
support et d'intérêt pour notre
pays bien sûr
que il est absolument nécessaire d'avoir
des résultats concrets je reviens
toujours sur le fait que on demande
l'adhésion à l'Union européenne mais on
demande aussi le support pour la mise en
œuvre de toutes les transformations
parce que on veut être un partenaire
crédible et fort dans la famille
européenne